this be risk of rain - - right now we
only have one character unlocked they
start with machine gun you know
so what basically you kill it it means
you earn money you can buy upgrades you
can buy a little robots that fly around
and help and upgrade turrets you can buy
little boxes that will give you perks
that might give you a higher chance to
inflict bleed or a higher chance for
critical hit or maybe you heal over time
or you can heal other people like it's a
fun experience I'm excited for you all
to experience it together with me yeah
I'm excited about this this is a good
thing
all the mouse sensitivity ah that's it's
not that bad what's up with the hawk oh
jeez Pavillion to low watch out for the
things in the sky what oh my god so we
just spawn in and instantly everything's
trying to kill us is that what you like
mark what you don't spawn in the game
and then everything's tries to kill you
in every roguelike this little doodad
over here we have to find a lunar which
is a coin I don't know if it just spawns
randomly or if something drops it
there's a big silver coin that when we
pick it up we got to bring it back here
oh god I actually have to concentrate on
the ship oh jeez oh yeah you do
oh my god that's a big thing over here
holy [ __ ] no dead oh the sky this guy
this guy want to find perks so like blue
crates or if you see an orange
tough-looking thing that'll give you an
ultimate ability and the ultimate
abilities can really save your ass okay
mark did you buy the trone no I didn't
do anything why is the gunner drone with
us
I bought one okay mark you got some
[ __ ] around you where I see oh my god
this is like situational awareness
overkill
like I killed it just wait I was waiting
yeah yeah the the first version of this
game gets so [ __ ] crazy yeah this is
nothing I can't thank you your first
character beds
these little guys are so like bounce
pads 30 I'm normal right if you look on
the right we have an objective to find
and activate a teleport what did I just
get oh and Bob Bob that thing you just
found you get to choose one of the three
things when you open that when I open
what No
me yeah you chose which one okay yeah I
did the tri-tip dagger I didn't know
what it did something about a bleed I
don't know yeah if you hit tab you can
see everyone's items Bob you've not
bought any items yet know how there's
the ear Bob right below if you want to
drop down you can buy this crate if you
want it is their fault oh god no oh [ __ ]
what was that Jesus something shot you
from above I thought yeah there's
something up a big cliff yeah I'm
getting them when do you get health
factor kills you heal back over time if
you come to this press you press a on
Ebola
down here it'll drop a perk you can grab
I feel nearby allies after standing
still for two seconds if you guys come
to me there's an ultimate ability up
here one of you can grab I already paid
for it's all yours
Bob you go ahead and go for it you grab
that glowing slug thing up there yeah
yeah that's your ultimate ability you
can fly temporarily I don't really want
to deal with flying so many things I'm
back here hello I'm I temporarily so
there's an orc it's the other ultimate
ability it's a black hole I don't I feel
how temporary until the [ __ ] to the
damage to them she's got a good a wave
thing I've got a single term at target
dps ultimate ability I've got two
gunning drones and a healing drone I'm
loaded can I offer $30 this run if
chance wait I forget the macaque I would
cautious slug rapidly heal outside of
danger nice chest here huh oh wait
there's another bustling fungus that's
that's the one that heals allies
actually it does more and more so if you
want to be like our primary stand still
he alert all right yeah I can heal
now that we've bought a lot of the perks
and stuff this is our teleporter when we
activate this a bunch of big bosses will
spawn and she'll get crazy do it oh I
see it's tough to buy overcome all of
all he's gonna do it never mind yeah oh
so many golems good god did you activate
the thing or what just happening oh
there is full damage and ouch oh I got
the tri-tip dagger chance to bleed
enemies on hit that's what you alright
mark yeah I got that and I got a
leeching seed which means I heal from
damage so that's pretty cool
yeah that's nice
that's a good one I think come down here
okay coming down here for you oh my god
I'm so glad they made this game okay got
it does it have any does it River run
out you can only use like once every 20
or 30 seconds oh I just used it all
right but it was cool yeah it was cool
when it happened look pretty cool
anybody do you see the top how we run
easy and it's about to tick over to
medium yeah yeah I do
the longer we sit here and kill [ __ ] the
harder things are gonna get going over
the next world
so theoretically you want to go through
this as fast as possible but I kind of
took this one it's like a learning yeah
you stupid idiot oh my god Margo they
wanted to go up towards the teleporter
okay okay okay here all right
this is getting thick I'm gonna think
about waiting till you guys get up here
to activate this saying he was gonna
think about it he didn't say he was
actually gonna do it did I was honest
well I felt I felt I felt god damnit
doctor all right this is a great time to
use your uh use it alright it's on
cooldown I use it on a small guy alright
I guess I'll just blackhole this I am
being a distraction okay used it here we
go does he have like a critical point if
I shoot him in his eye isn't any better
is it all the same I know of but it's
possible
well he's targeting me there we go man
what an easy boss alright so now some
shits gonna spawn around here Oh usually
grab one or two of them okay I got I got
slow enemies on hit which is and now
we're done here so we can take this
teleporter Livas is it's a Chargers have
to stay inside the AoE
[Music]
that's new I don't like when you say
that wait I like it when you know what's
happening charged 97 98 all right oh oh
I had 905 dollar a nose shrine I'm gonna
do the trench line before we go hang on
[Laughter]
all right like a gunner drone that's
what I would like I'm good yeah I are is
not reload I'll go on my own guys I'll
be fine don't worry about me that guy's
fast I don't like it anymore I'm coming
back to you guys I don't want to be by
myself it's all right I see oh now I do
that's expensive yeah I was like 260 or
something right oh my god mark they're
not dying
none of them are dying how do we die
them the whole bunch into a black hole
there hope it helped you it didn't what
these guys have an AoE around them and
they also shoot that giant be concerned
I'll kill you
yeah all right I'm gonna heal I'll run
I'll run away really fast and get all
the items thanks mark sharing is caring
come on down here I'm in the thick of it
what are you talking about well we just
moved in a medium approaching hard well
I mean this is pretty easy I don't know
what you guys are talking about right
now Yeah right whatever all right so I
would like a drone if anyone finds a
gunner drone if I could get that that'd
be a real dope okay we'll leave it I
want to sue this guitar dust I bought a
guitar guitar a guitar and his ukulele I
guess my music was electric
what says I will say we should
definitely keep exploring
yeah 3d printer I'm here one items was
that I just sacrificed an item I guess
Oh farmer Oh deal extra damage some
bosses well that's handy
also the birds you know you can see pots
they expel them on me yeah I've noticed
that they hurt gain gold on a hit but
lose gold when you get hit that's
dangerous
my character model seems to be bugged I
have I have my ultimate constantly out
but like it's expired now so it
shouldn't be out
that's not good looking for drones are
you guys don't know can't items Bobby
yeah yeah there's a bunch of killing a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah that's the thing I'm
really bad at in this game is you have
to sort of balance fighting with
exploring I just get really wrapped up
in like killing the [ __ ] out of
everything that I find well I have more
med kits I have so many stuff on my
bodies there a limit to what you can
carry
I don't know it's that forest full
possibly but oh I'm gonna buy this oh
[ __ ] I died you died there's like a
death thing over here does that does
that do anything for me they're back
there's no resurrection mechanic no you
just come back today if we beat the
level you come back the next level huh
we need to find a teleporter yeah I
don't see a teleporter anywhere I don't
see pretty much anything oh you're right
there I'm just hurting myself for money
don't we all don't we all wait Oh Oh get
in that bubble it does more damage in
the bubble climbing on that I know of
there's a giant boss on me okay all
right well I thought we should go over
towards Wade I mean I guess if we have
to I got a chance to fire a missile hell
yeah
there's just something on a hill up here
that I have no idea how would you even
get to it might be that coin thing that
Wade was talking about is it like a
silver looking thing I mean it's it
looks like some kind of a chest it looks
a little gray I guess I don't know it's
hard to say we should definitely try to
get to it began it's up on a Ledge I
have no idea how anyone would actually
get up to it one of you guys said that
you might fly but that's the only way
that I could imagine oh yeah yeah it's
up in the side of a mountain up over
here we got drones I don't have any
drones I've literally no drones honey no
drones
I got four marques all over the drone
okay I do I probably do have all the
drones in some six shades I also have
those but you know it's not my fault
alright so where's the sting mark stop
over I'm shooting at it think you could
fly up there yeah try that because
that's definitely a thing it's no idea
what is whoa
oh nice that's actually pretty cool it's
the lunar thing we don't have one of
those
oh never mind then where do you get a
lunar coin Wade we need one like it's on
the map somewhere I think big flying's
the big silver coins should be hard to
miss but it will try to be tucked away
somewhere I don't know there's a lot of
[ __ ] on you I know I'm not helping with
you I got the drug I got the groans I
got the drones I'm good I've got $2,000
you guys yeah I got 1,600 nothing to
spend it on is that where's a mystery
shrine or something I'll just fork it
all over in there right does anybody
want a new alt there's a new ultimate
ability down here what is it is it
better it is what I've not seen before I
don't know what it does
ocular HUD sure let's try it hundred
percent critical strike for eight
seconds oh that's kind of cool but I
like the missile launchers better I
think yeah Bob do would you rather have
a critical strike you're flying maybe
I'd rather have flying okay where's Ella
border I am going back over kind of
where we started and just see if we
missed me offshoots oh [ __ ] a giant ass
goal I'm just spawned on me well kill it
I keep going in circles
yeah whoo my god it's murdering me I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming I'm running
away from it towards you mark it's
[ __ ] oh yeah that's big I'm making a
lot of enemies spawn on the way over to
it that's unfortunate our difficulties
ramping up fast that we're really
progressing I found the coin oh oh I
found the lunar coin okay oh Sh I should
have given that to Bob oh [ __ ] oh my god
mark there are so many things over I see
I see I see yeah
I'm currently dealing with as many as I
can try to hit me try to hit me there's
a big gold down there yes yeah he'd be
big boy he big boy and he dead boy okay
yeah you need a little juice here come
stand in my circle [ __ ] all
right you guys should go get the lunar
coin
I got it how do I give it to Bob or is
it just like globally we have it Bobby
and your currency do you see do you see
a coin look at her purple dollar below
your dollar oh [ __ ] oh there's that
critical item next to it we can exchange
I can take the fly okay then I'll switch
you back to fly afterwards and then you
can have all the coins from now on go
pick it up I'll pick up the other one
got a bing bada boom yes okay how does
it work
you have to kick you and then space this
up maybe not ocular yeah oh here we go
weird okay got it I don't know it did
what did it do a blue orb appears it
says I don't know what that means what
did it do
I don't know all right I'm dropping off
my my ultimate here we go switching out
oh boy look I have to fight here yep
there is I don't I feel like we're
missing something
all right we're about to cross over into
insane is that good no that's bad that's
probably fine what are you worried about
because we haven't fought this boss what
boss there's a boss let me check over
here I don't know if we've gone up here
wait the red rope the red rope what does
that mean oh [ __ ] oh that's what it
means don't go don't go inside the red
rope yeah yeah don't go outside it it's
bad news um yeah I have no clue I feel
like it's it would be obvious I mean it
should be you get 11 looters you can
unlock a character oh I don't expect us
to make it to round 11 at our current
pace no even [ __ ] fly the teleporter
I don't understand about a third of the
way into insane and we still have found
the second boss's teleporter whatever I
found it it's right here it's right next
to the [ __ ] lunar thing what was
right next to the lunar thing all right
coming right trigger that [ __ ] and
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
I guess what I tell marks here but I'm
almost there oh I'm lagging balls go
down here I assume few people went down
here I thought one of us did wait where
is it this is the teleporter where what
is the silly what are you saying
I have to press this to activate it
pressing it there's one thing on our
screaming yeah there's nothing on our
screens it's not here for you no no oh
boy oh boy that's uh that's a big boy
that's a little boys too oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
god oh god oh my god oh god that hurts a
lot clear some of these Flyers because
they're [ __ ] and picking me apart
here
Oh God the Flyers the other Flyers all
got the Flyers that are so many flyers
what is this I got a lunar coin one of
the Flyers dropped the lunar coin nice
good holy [ __ ] me Wow
you guys okay oh no no no no don't shoot
that at me don't shoot that at me I
don't want any that oh my god man this
planet really doesn't want us to be here
yeah impossible yet oh don't worry we'll
get there
eat my black hole [ __ ] yeah one of them
is down got it cool I'm gonna charge the
other one coming at me come on don't
come at me don't come at me stop coming
at me oh god stop we're back in the
bubble we gotta keep charging the thing
back at the oh [ __ ] I'm not even in the
bubble I'm an idiot what is that it's a
tea pot Oh God
spider tea Milo the tea pots are tea
pots later how big is it a giant oh it's
big oh it's big oh that's big shooting
missiles to shoot missiles
oh yeah it's it's almost here incoming
incoming incoming incoming No No Oh God
once it locks on it it doesn't let go oh
one down tea party bulbs down goals down
I'll go grab my drones it's taking our
drones I'm grab another one of these
okay well yeah no come back you'll come
back next level yeah I need to go look
at something apparently something
horrible is happening to our house oh no
oh go take care of it okay there's a lot
of [ __ ] here to kill at the teleporter
one of them's up okay mark there's items
around here I got one yeah I picked it
up won a Titanic canoe roll we can take
the teleport you just want to go uh yeah
why not oh I shouldn't go cuz Bob's not
here yet
Oh true oh we can hold off I clicked it
low oh never mind then no this [ __ ] just
never ends does it hidden realm bizarre
between time what is our means shop does
that mean there's a shop here this was a
hidden portal not like the portal portal
oh yeah this looks this looks like
something there's something here but I
wouldn't shoot at it it's not shooting
at me oh it's a place that costs lunar
coins oh I got none Bob so one of these
two by a character right probably is a
dude here there's ten lunar coins or
whatever this is not good looks like Oh
God we're in that we're in the
difficulty I see you that's not good
final items to get this some kind of
soup
George I don't reforge me maybe it just
changes all of your items or something I
don't know
now let's try it I might go for it never
mind I can't you don't have the stuff
right I don't know but I'm in the soup
oh god Bob please come back the
difficulties just continue to wrap-up I
think it's okay we're gonna do we're
gonna die we're gonna dude we're gonna
dude it up I see you I'll get you it's
rather intimidating when we shoot this
guy I don't go love it Oh something
tells me that's bad hey Bob just like we
need to go be brief you do it we're in a
secret level apparent we're in a bizarre
how many I have one lunar okay that's
not it before anything but we're in a
safe bazaar but the difficulty is still
going up it's uh up to ICU now oh so we
need to get the [ __ ] out of here
part of our gutter had fallen off oh
[ __ ] out in the rain and like jammed it
back in so whoa this guy's like a demon
or something things lose a bison I'm
killing about that Oh God the army the
army is here which army the minion army
army don't teleport don't teleport I
don't like that yeah yeah that's what
Mark was talking about didn't you hear
me yellow oh boy a pool demon there are
those - yes oh my god this guy we need
to kill the green thing in the sky oh
there's Gollum spawning oh my sweet
Jesus
whoa I got something in me all of my
attacks explode now yes nice come come
give him that dick mark I'm coming I'm
coming
I really need someone to do all there's
golems between us there's so many gold
it's okay all my attacks explode
apparently I don't know I don't think
it's more damage I just think it's a OE
now yeah well if you can do damage to
crowds oh yeah I got rounds deal extra
damage to bosses okay okay yeah we can
even see where the portal is shrine of
combat
boy that's some ins [ __ ] guys I'm sorry
wait win if ride of combat I did you
[ __ ] madman yeah look at this mad lad
over here I am running away to find loot
oh [ __ ] I'm almost dead oh [ __ ] don't
die don't die no no please thought we
need you for the bosses you guys need
healing friends it's okay it's okay I'm
coming I'll do a little healing aura
right here I hear ya where I don't know
I gotta look up wait and I are behind
you on the Left okay no I was at 60
health so I think I just I just I just
[ __ ] off a heel on you so I like it
okay shrine of combat was a bad idea I
just want to say that might be my bad
okay Bob I have a feeling we're not
gonna make it very far so we'll see you
on the other side very soon and
apparently you do a lot of damage
goddamn me yeah yeah mark yeah
thankfully it's my only saving grace at
the moment what is this
combat shrine yeah let's not do that
yeah
turn invisible on taking heavy damage oh
no you did not pop one okay what does
this try and look like again I'd what is
the thing we're looking for a look like
a oh boy
Oh mark you got some oh god oh I can't
move [ __ ] I can't move
oh there I'll seal it no guard mark
you're invisible good Hey whoo-hoo you
give me something good
so glasses yes
mark got cool guys sunglasses yes what I
got man that's what I got I just can't
do enough to kill anybody anymore
that's my main problem we're in - I'm
coming for you I don't know if that's
okay yeah do it where are you coming oh
it's real dark Oh
demons Aldo that's the worst thing are
you gonna die I can use anymore until we
beat him that's all right well let's
let's do this come on I'm ready it's
dead just gonna say that now you're not
dead yet I'd be probably but he stopped
taking as much damage as he had been
taking oh that guy spawned on you oh my
god thank you it's all me all day all me
all me all day I got this
you want some of this huh what is this -
I don't know if I'm using it it's a fan
this was a bad idea why map Oh oh my god
the giant demons jumping is line you
need it get in the circle okay it's all
good it's all good so so much trust and
faith in you right now I got this guy's
yeah me too me too
oh [ __ ] oh I accidentally used my heel
at the wrong time I'm gonna get off then
you can have it you can have the high
ground
they're big okay I'm gonna run and I'm
just gonna run I need to get to the
jumpy I need to get the high ground
again also they do so much damage yes it
happens everybody okay area and then the
portals open now I'm gonna gun it I
don't need to kill him to get the portal
[ __ ] I think you need to kill we get the
portal open guys
just gotta get the bosses then right
okay is he big boss boys in the sky they
hurt I don't want out I'm not worried
about them I just got a yeah I just
laser focus right now just hang on
everything I'm aware everything things I
only got one of them down good two good
guys I'm too good too good pro skills
[ __ ] where they go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay
just gotta go okay now's my chance I'm
going over here in three two one
where'd they go oh [ __ ]
cool great good good good great good
good oh my god oh my god hey you're
really not killing anything nope not oh
there they are
hey what are you doing up there I'll
come up to him don't worry about cool
who he wants to die he does he does want
to die not well no I'm aware I'm aware
of the situation and they're gone again
but seriously that's a big hike uh-huh
but I think I got this I think I got
this guy's you heal a lot thank you i
[ __ ] on a feeling it's insane yeah it's
my damage it's my big big greasy damage
where'd they go
oh where are the friends oh they're all
my drones they're finding my drones for
some reason Oh ever mind that's the zone
I thought he was teleporting up on to
you it was just this oh okay oh okay the
little guys hurt more than the big guys
apparently hey my drones are making it
happen a man I wish I had some drone you
know let me see if I can just finish off
this guy I can't believe this is working
Thrones huh yeah I can't either
so it's all good it's all good oh my god
okay that's fine all right he's going
down he's going down he's going down
come on
what's yes one teleporter yo how do i
roll buckler what does that make up all
that pick up all that God I got the
items okay I'm good here we go you're
gonna be [ __ ] invincible don't give
me the snakes oh Jesus
okay all right well this is a problem
why did we go to hell I don't do any
damage to any of these things what am I
supposed to do about this
ah don't sue fire at me what did you
that what's that pot advant there's an
$8,000 crate down here why I have like a
lizard guy chasing me and I really need
help I don't know where you are I'm
still in the starting area listen guys
Jesus I'm gonna die I'm gonna go down
I'm probably at some point here I'm
gonna try to come away oh I'm coming to
you now I'm gonna run I got the less
damage when I run so I'm just gonna come
to you oh there's so much bad yeah yeah
there yeah yep that's yep okay hey Mark
you're coming to me oh no no I'm going
right past you you get no no wait that's
even worse that means mark mark mark
mark mark oh no not me no I should be
the one to survive I should be the one
who's dead okay we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah big lizard big lizard potted
plant big lizard gonna die okay all
right
Oh dead I'm dead I'm dead no you're the
only good one of us what you guys run
away then I got wiped out from like top
to bottom in zero seconds so I was in
the middle of like everything I think
the snake got me like explosions went
off everything happened this is in this
game is no joke
where's the rain there's no rain it's
only a risk of rain okay
oh that's a big lizard boy Wade fleas
those hurt a lot don't wait flee I think
those are the ones that touched me I did
they touch me a lot it was like ah those
killed you're right there on him he's
sorry he's at me he's at he's angry at
me I don't have a lot of health anymore
wait it was $6.99 $6.99 whatever that I
have 43 health I know where to stand
still Bob you're fine I believe in you I
got a turret what are you gonna do for
me turret do stuff oh just gonna throw
that Bob Bob care fly through a black
hole in that general direction that
snake thing really needs to go away I
don't think there's anything to be done
about that oh goodness me the thing I
need you oh oh you almost said you're so
Dee I know Bob are you dead yeah it's
the seat bud okay well this is exactly
what I've planned for I was ready for
this day all right okay cool
shrine at the mountain I pray to thee o
you invited the challenge of the
mountain
[Music]
it's clearly not fine the shrine can
only be good it's a teleporter it's got
to be good they really they're really
right all over you yeah well Wow oh wow
Bob you did not get a lot of items no
bottom all in the first two worlds want
to go again yes yes new guy Huntress
what no cuz you survived the first
I don't know it just says I got a
hundred oh you guys don't have hunters
oh oh I'm sorry oh look at me look oh
look at oh the so cool yes
oh look at my glaive bounce between them
cool what what was behind the start I
was amazed Moe's behind us I got them
are you buying all this goddamn it no I
bought one I bought one I opened one
each as money so I can buy this drone
all right god I gotta get a drone I
would not buy that that's not a movable
one I'm an idiot mark there's a blood
shrine Oh sprinting is toggle you don't
have to hold it down yes every time you
do anything at unspring soo which is an
orange I found a gun or drone but I'm
only gonna use this one it's the only
drone all have okay and then you if I
find another drone you guys can have
them whoa what the [ __ ] did I do that
was so cool guys the Huntress is like
really cool sounds cool it is it is cool
all we have to do is live get to the
third area man I have so much month I
wish I could spend it on something
seriously all these things are [ __ ]
purchased what the [ __ ] I I'm sorry
there's a stun grenade here oh the the
flying thing do you want the flying
thing Bob it's down where I am on
someone else can have that I'll take it
old war stealth kit I think that's the
thing that makes you go invisible when
you take any damage nearby enemies on
fire oh you could ping you can ping with
middle-mouse some what a lovely bird
just told me oh well hey teleporters
right there okay how's it going pretty
good pretty good watch this where the
item set oh that's cool
pretty sick pretty sick whoa my blink is
very far these are there's more items
down yeah there's two items down there
I'm a wasp I'm a stinging literally
literally just nodding I'm activating it
guys I hope you unlock the hunters
because I really like the Huntress he's
really cool am I in the zone I feel like
I'm not seeing the activation thing for
the
I'm not seeing it either flinches we are
currently at 43% all right you guys are
both on the teleporter right now I'm
flying
whoa-ohh all right let's kill this [ __ ]
to get the [ __ ] out of here
weights dead it's problem when you kill
it don't forget to grab all three perks
that drop okay there's one here go for
it
oh my god I'm so dead do the thing do
the thing do the thing I got a dude
thing to 85% charged mark and I can't
see it we can't do the thing it'll do it
when it shows up I think it'll be fine
it's up should be up see and the thing
you guys are marked right that way walk
that way
your left a little bit yeah stay like
two steps to your left two steps to your
life right now prissy I'm crushing me
it's not working no no no that's a weird
buys this is awkward
look at that ass look at that ass maybe
and broken or some thought sure that's a
row you guys might be able to see the
teleport yeah it's weird
oh well but that was cool huh all right
let's hope we can see it this time
oh I don't have my wings anymore no no
the wings are fun yeah man the huntress
does have quite a but I just got to say
if you think though oh she thick yeah
I'm gonna go on the let's spread out
strategy on this one I'm just trying to
find [ __ ] let me go I'm gonna pick a
route then come out to me bros where are
you what is this a randomizer
nice and calm right now trying to chance
nothing god damn it
you get the level up thing work the best
sure did I sure did a lot of shrines a
chance I didn't win my first bed but
maybe my gamble you gamble in man yes I
am here I go
I got rewarded today oh I got I got two
War banners what good does that give me
I think it's either a bigger bonus or
bigger AoE bigger dick I'm hoping that
with the teleporter is not an invisible
piece of [ __ ] this round no I see it I
can see it okay guys there's not enough
enemies there really isn't pretty light
I guess it as escalates really quickly
oh damn mark thanks man thing just
bounces from [ __ ] - [ __ ] ya do ya do
another war banner [ __ ] I picked it up
before I could be like hey so what I was
gonna war banner huh I got the the eyes
on the thing should we just do the
teleporter I got there's a couple more
boxes around we should try to open it
soon can't you open them afterwards
though no I'm not sure I think they stay
locked that could be wrong I'm gonna
pray to the shrine of them I got a red
whip all the shrine of the mountain that
sounds good move fast out of combat
I got a ukulele huh oh that does oh
thanks man I'm really jealous that the
Huntress I don't know if I'm it is right
up your alley is right up your alley
yeah this is this is like your character
and she's fun to look at so that's an
added bonus um try to combat guys good
luck okay I don't don't know where it is
we want to be inside of ya there bonus
damage oh my god they did all spot on
you look at that yeah I was not waiting
you have so many friends over here
popular you are my dude try to the
mountain hit it I did you thought I was
gonna wait no no I guess not you know
this is more like a hype man I have two
of them now what the forget nothing
screw you give me something there we go
that's some time talking about our you
know game look for you it's bad please
no don't do it no you got a problem you
know you're right you know you're right
I know I'm right I'm the gambling good
job
do it for it do it come on you won't no
balls oh yeah oh yeah right yeah prove
it you think I won't no I don't think
you will no yeah well yeah Wow
you think I won't something frost relic
all the frost relic you know you know
killing enemies surrounds you with
icicles the [ __ ] does that mean
holy [ __ ] I've got ice hit the thing
where it's a lot yeah someday we're
coming up
so what's all this it's locked up here
oh there's drones because there's three
of these things I don't remember there
being three last time oh there's four oh
my god destroy the mountain did oh [ __ ]
guys I'm dead don't die
oh my god they're big yeah Bobby I see
we should go why aren't you up fighting
I'm getting my icicles no I did but I'm
dead oh boy oh boy oh boy you got this
come on guys Oh No get me again
Oh oh god oh god oh god so close wait
were you down below wait listen wait
abandoned you like he abandoned me
earlier I guess that's true you're right
oh you're right
wait you're kind of being a bit of a
baby I need you to stop being a baby
about this I playing tactic that's not
like a judgmental snarky laughs it was
oh yeah it was you wanted to be a more
obvious yeah oh yeah it would be nice if
we had mark I agree it would be nice it
would be nice I don't disagree with that
yeah I got it
you're almost there oh we're doing it I
can see that let me leave to see where
weight is oh yeah wait as far as he
could possibly be away there's cover in
there you know wait wait you've got two
of the bosses bob has joined bosses
everything I've killed everything else
I'm very power that's not how this works
boss down one day I bobbin coven ah
Oh I rolled into your fire you scumbag
I believe in you I've heard you know I
heard that from some 100 of these
tucking under Oh what's he doing a
marker you see in this wait oh yeah what
the [ __ ] oh sweet Jesus
ha oh gosh oh god it was really fun when
he was stuck under the arch first time
yeah I can see that was really helpful
I'm here Bob does this mean they're
gonna spawn like quadruple the rewards
12 items I'm just like we're all here to
reap those ah yeah me too me me - me me
- all right I'm about to pop one he'd a
nice nice nice dead you guys got how did
I believe in you her life is life is
good well he's not shooting all his
[ __ ] lasers and explosions at you
[Laughter]
sprint defenses for the Huntress 3 no
those that have been perfect for my
Huntress know many Rose buckler's right
yeah let's go get the drones yeah go get
him go get him guys
you go get him drones are really helpful
right yeah I've heard yeah whatever it's
okay all right I guess I'll you know
whatever I did it for you yeah just go
through you're good
both tries there my drones I am drone
boy all right I'm doing the thing I'm
not drone boy I'm droning this girl
we're doing the thing let's go
nice Wade you're gonna make it oh so
close it's so close Wade you didn't make
it no all right I'm back baby
you want me to activate the challenge of
the mountain whatever you do here we go
I got that really shitty mushroom thing
that just allows me to heal everyone
else cool thanks bro that's pretty much
all I'm good for
I got an alt the pro fire cost gold per
bullet oh yeah does it like do more
damage it does after the teleporter
image per hit Oh what you're even
looking at me how the [ __ ] did you just
target me [ __ ] you oh hey there's a
bunch of you I can only blink forwards
with the hunters that's not a good thing
well you could snap around [ __ ] I'm dead
well that's not so good
Oh Shi that guy [ __ ] me up what guy it
was it was just a big mountain slammer
dude yeah it was just really really
inconvenient cuz every time I was trying
to like blink away from him I would
blink straight towards him cuz oh with
the hunters you only blink forward you
can't like with the other one you combat
roll backwards that's what I was trying
to do and it did not work did you win
yeah we won real right cool
good job man I don't like to do
character mark what you get verified
what I don't know where the character
actually is hit continue never mind we
need the time sorry whoa geez lock the
ball team
you know you want to go again cuz I'm
down to go again yeah I can do one more
alright let's do this how did you unlock
that one Wade I think it was just by
completing like five matches or
something
oh yeah ready up I was trying to read my
dudes abilities that's funny to know
what they are you don't know what the
only has four abilities read faster I
think it's complicated yeah once you
start unlocking the advanced classes the
advanced classes oh look a troll I don't
sprint I roll that's fun oh that's what
the hell are the enemies don't they
usually spawn here whoa nice machine gun
there's a teleporter hey you see it
right there yeah I see it okay my
objective is to not die this time
that's a good objective I would very
much appreciate that because I would
like if you didn't [ __ ] us again oh oh I
[ __ ] you maybe you're black of skill
[ __ ] do you all that I invited the
challenge of the mountain and cool-cool
cool-cool cool-cool
despite how we treat each other we are
all teammates what I'm winning you guys
suck I'm winning again [ __ ] yes I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to live
without double jump please be good don't
be good to wait whatever happens milky
crystals oh yeah these nails fire like
slowly so it's really hard to hit flyers
or anything that moves for that matter
whoa I found it happiest mask it's a
horrible mask
guys I'm you might not want to look at
me in the face anymore I didn't already
the same you might [ __ ] twice with
nothing
[ __ ] the shrine a chance it's [ __ ]
mmm-hmm alright you want to hit the
thing a shrine chance yeah we give it a
little get a little douche all right I'm
gonna hit the shrine of the mountain
before I do it so we get an extra spicy
challenge right that's what you guys
want
sure do we have all the wrong [ __ ]
I don't think there were very many
drones here yeah yeah there's like not
very many more items just hang on and
don't do it yet okay all right it's for
no reason about it so chill for a second
really really looking at it but chance
oh this right chance no no let me gamble
no and let me do it let me do it no let
me do it come on please let me do it
ha I got it let me do it let me do it
let me do it your boys on the offense
today yeah hell yeah are you ready yeah
ready to throw down ready for this huh
can I get a hell yeah yeah those are
mine it's my mask I kill him and
sometimes I summon ghosts they're on my
side why you're so hideous I'm beautiful
I don't know but I quote I'm hideous
don't look at me how beautiful I am
shut up least don't look at me what it's
red well you might didn't you say
something I said 10 [ __ ] times
are we ready ready ready I want a
confirmation about this I want to be
sure it's not my problem are the big
green things from the sky the bosses yes
right now they're shooting them all
those green things
what other green things that was a
shield the other two were I kept two of
these they were easy
we're almost through the field captain
which one of us is Captain huh well not
the robot I don't think I'm qualified
either captain because I'm commando
Bowie oh so so a woman couldn't be
captain is that what you're saying huh
you're like the assassin yeah whatever I
could be a captain yeah so the assassin
can't be captain yeah what are you
saying huh
I'm gonna go get this medical drone
Scotia's Oh gross
I grabbed two things mark this two
feathers here for you two feathers okay
coming coming coming oh my god these
feathers another jump holy [ __ ] really
their owns anywhere look I've got three
feathers total now [ __ ] yeah oh yes I
love that oh that hurts
yeah you got to be careful with the fall
dance all right yeah let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go why is there
an invisible douchebag over here oh whoa
hey there's my ghost oh that's your
ghost okay oh he died it's okay they do
that
oh I opened this on accident an effigy
of grief that sounds good drop an effigy
that cripples all characters inside what
I'll take the flying one why would I
want to [ __ ] all of us well probably
cripples enemies as well because yes
otherwise that doesn't make a lot of
sense all right I'm gonna go explore as
fun as it is to kill a bunch of [ __ ] all
in this one area you gotta get the money
I'm a hoppy [ __ ] rhobar deal more
damage to healthy enemies found the
teleporter oh god I'm dying are you
dying don't die I'm dying wait did I not
pick up Oh God I'm an idiot
oh god am i dumb oh god guys I'm dumb I
think I bought a nighttime way back at
the beginning and I didn't pick it up
that would be dumb that would be really
dumb if I did that which there's no
confirmation that I did all right I'm
gonna go explore as fun as it is to kill
a bunch of [ __ ] all in this one area are
we teleporting are we exploring a little
bit more looks like I didn't that's a
big negative on that one yep didn't grab
it got it wait no go for it all right
I'm doing the thing let's [ __ ] rock
this okay all right let's just do this
and get the character need the [ __ ] out
of your nose why does it have boobs oh
no wait that's just a thorax I saw it
from the side I thought
we know what you're thinking about mr.
oh yeah boobs
I dropped my effigy on it it works yeah
it's like stuck in there ha ha they
[ __ ] by my sweet effigy I'm flying I'm
a bird I'm a bird is dead question mark
oh it's dead
I'm grabbing one of these coins there's
one for each of us ok I don't sue oh I
see where they're coming I'm really slow
right now I got slowed shall we go shall
we [ __ ] out of here that effigy oh wait
got to pick it back up
Oh Oh interesting left it once wisp is
dying don't worry about those are my
ghosts ok they just die slowly
yeah they die do the things unlock the
thing then order way to do this one as
well we have to clear three of them is
this the third one or the second one
third should be the third one so we got
to get through this one as well to do
what without dying unlock your character
I think oh yeah unlock the character you
are Oh makes sense oh my god I want this
is this a drone is this a drone that
comes with me they can't hit me if I
hear this you can buy this for 3300
buckos Jesus if you want to save up for
it I got a lunar oh [ __ ]
you don't can we I want that whatever
this is oh [ __ ] go god oh god oh god
I got something that's like a ground
slam I don't know why nice I've got my
effigy of destruction oh wow oh cool I
think if I Boop someone in the head they
they could take damage bonk I do the
brittle girl oh gain gold on hit lose
gold on getting hit I see it's kind of a
bit of a monkey's paw a little bit
except I can fly cheap death once all if
I die come back once that's nice that's
pretty nice
all right over a thousand man are you
gonna get an I think you got to like
fight the boss and then come back to it
I don't know I'm getting money pretty
quickly here
yeah 1200 now I can really sky and
really ground pound some people there's
a lot of bad [ __ ] on the bright Bob
you've got to be getting close I've got
class I've got almost 1900 I don't know
what this big thing is oh the three
thousand dollar one what does that do I
don't know I just want to buy it all
right I didn't I only want to finish
this and then buy that thing and help it
hopefully before we do the boss fight I
guess Matt 2268 so I'm getting there
cautious luck what the hell is a
cautious slug lets you heal when you're
outside of combat
are there any combat totems not that I
saw I went around the entire complex I
didn't see anything
plus I missed it which is very likely
I'm twenty eight seventy and there's a
couple golems here I'm ready
twenty nine seventy two twenty three
thousand oh boy alright I'm gonna go buy
the thing and see what happens oh it's a
giant it's a giant gun drove clear out
some fliers first I'm coming to you oh
my god it does so much damage holy Foley
[ __ ] it shit's damaged yeah did you just
take my crowbar that I gambled
I bought that oh you did that you did
that that was you okay well did you just
take the curl borrow is gonna steal from
you and this shit's getting real
we should probably we need to go yeah we
need to do this right now yep I don't
know where it went
I I think I saw it a while back but I
have no idea where it is now
oh yeah here it is alright I'm throwing
it yeah go ahead
what is oh it's the spider things yeah
Oh God fighter teapots Oh for your big
dudes coming in though Bob it's time oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna bop it I'm gonna bop it
I'm gonna bop it I'm gonna bop em on the
head
okay this is gonna be very bad for me
what the [ __ ]
what Oh what happened
wait what hit me are you dead
yeah yeah mark out one shot oh wait oh
wait hey you I didn't kill MIT I was
almost dead okay
oh mama oh man if you guys die because I
died I'm gonna feel real bad yeah don't
really I had so much good [ __ ] like so
much good [ __ ] oh god oh yeah we've--
you really gotta stop running away like
a little baby listen I like to live I
like life Oh even the drone goes down
when Bob went down way to go Wade wait
really really did it really did it hey
buy it oh I don't think I can I think
it's you just read over his body you
without a care
well I guess my effigy failed since back
in life a person again
drop it oh my god you really and you
were still ran away in the beginning god
damn it you have the most help you have
double all our hell for the [ __ ] word
you're the coward right I am you're not
only the fast it's two cents just just
die like a champ I think Bob don't you
have to go yeah yeah just go in there
die like a champ and well this is the
most exciting fight ever do one damage
at a time to this giant [ __ ] murder
teapots at least don't leave me alone up
here right like this this does seem like
kind of a broken angle nailed it
Oh where'd they go under you that's good
oh no they're inside the thing it's good
that you left there
I can't jump when I'm in that ability
apparently that's oh do you just have a
runaway ability that just like Sprint's
you in one direction yeah I also do a
lot of damage where I hit things with
that well just go Ram them then yeah I
died because I tried to headbutt it but
uh you know no one can help you now I
have an ability if I ground pound it
does like 3000 damage so I'm gonna yeah
boy
you could have shot at him you know that
wasn't exactly doing a lot of damage
your your cowardly instincts are just I
think they're hindering you hey they're
coming over here you can go back in your
super high spot I think they healed all
the damage you just did not heal it okay
yeah I think when they did the sucky
thing they healed oh I want Chad to be
able to see how this ends but holy [ __ ]
alright don't worry guys I've almost got
him okay
yeah you've made like a centimeter of
progress in the last ten minutes no real
fun you get a new Shaun wait there they
go you don't damage
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah well the podcast continues yeah
from then on yeah yeah yeah I mistake
I'm gonna leave the visuals up goodbye
that's that's fine no don't leave yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna actually I'm just
gonna switch games cuz I'm gonna go to
no pixel and I'm gonna I'm gonna play
GTA well he didn't respond so I guess I
can't really do anything about it so you
know it is what it is what it is what's
dead all right cool man that's great
that's really good yeah
uh-huh friends homies guys they left me
guys
I did it I did it guys I'm here now huh
Mac what's up it's over it's over
uh-huh cool come back to life super cool
wow you still here
No what's the life we're still alive and
we're still alive
well guys are you willfully not talking
to us sir I'm talking hello Bob you're
here bark you're here guys I guess guess
this is it
oh wait I'm here you there you guys not
hear me be there I was talking to you
can you guys hear me hello yes
oh hey no good what I don't think you
can hear me Bob Bobby died mark he died
know who left just took me out with you
has been lived in it's gone no cuz death
what oh no you didn't get the well that
makes me feel a little way but I thought
I thought you had three I thought yeah
but I technically died my item just
brought me back are you dying [ __ ] Bob
and I you I totally imagine that yes
you're right I'll take full blame for
that
[Music]